hey hey cortex come here this is the  entrance to our annual chili pepper run  it's a death-defying obstacle course  that only crash can unlock I know it's  really important to make sure everything  goes smoothly for the synchronisation  celebration but this is too cool to miss  if you see crash set him over will you  welcome to the chili pepper run I'm so  excited for you to finally try it now  don't forget the more crates you get the  more awesome prizes you can win as long  as you don't you know get crushed I want  to say that I've really really  thoroughly tested it for you but all of  my test runners kind of got squished by  the giant bowling ball so it's an  experiment it'll be great you'll be  great  you'll be the best crate getter of all  time let's sell your biggest fan